this is Startalk so Matt Eli from Earth
and also Facebook wants to know this and
let's say Superman obeys the laws of
physics okay alright so now we are
suspending a lot of disbelief that uh
how does he fly could he use magnetism
dark energy seamless transfer of his own
mass to energy and air propulsion
through his skin pores what would be the
thing that caused a humanoid form to
take flight without the use of wings or
a rocket now when I was a kid and I saw
a Superman you know as a kid you want to
be a superhero right and right at least
I did and my favorite superhero was
Mighty Mouse and here I come to say that
because he sang opera and that was just
cool if I want to save women I want to
do it so while singing singing opera and
he had that that operatic yeah it was a
tenor I guess yeah so any and he had a
big powerful chest and he would save the
damsel and so I thought if that kind of
super I wanted to be now Mighty Mouse
had a cape yes and Superman had a cape
yes
so to me I was it was clear the decay
that makes your fly exactly was clearly
the case right so that I put on a cape
and I tried jumping and I didn't jump
I measured that I didn't jump any
farther wearing a cape than without a
cape so then I abandoned the idea that
the cape made you fly right he's like
when I was in third grade or something
okay so so so I so no capes no capes oh
no no no so you what you have to rely on
is his muscular strength from a planet
that might have a very high surface
gravity it's really what you had to now
he came here as an infant Moses style
right launched in a basket yeah ride in
a basket didn't age at all probably came
through a wormhole so he can get here
without aging and so but he grows up
with the strength of what he would have
had on his home planet right so if
you're that strong then you jump you
looks
looks like you're flying when in fact
you just jump [ __ ] is leaping you're
just leaping right and so look at how
much the Hulk leaps the hope can maybe
bump ya and he's he named Wayne Kate bro
yeah exactly it just wearing some really
sexy cut-offs
you know I've never looked at the Hulk
and thought you're sexy dude you know
I'm sorry no man it's kind of cold took
off his shirt that's some cutoff jeans
on I need some construction bit ha ha we
could talk well he's that he's the 6
Village People guy right so with her
five I don't know after lost count so so
he was very very strong and she can leap
these great distances almost like he's
flying so and if you remember Superman
what's the UH Superman begins it was
Batman Begins Batman Begins but a
Superman has origins one of the movies
was about his origins uh when he finally
sort of realizes these powers he's
jumping right that's how he starts off
that's how he starts just leaping right
there you can leap so far and I would
say if you're going to be a Superman
that's real you have extreme strength
which you know you need to bend steel
with her bare hands and that strength
would then translate into your ability
to jump and to leap very far distances
looking like you're flying which is by
the way the original intro to Superman
and the television series was able to
leap tall buildings in a single bound
tall bill right so it wasn't it never
said able to fly tall buildings right
able to leap tall buildings it's it's it
he were to obey the laws of physics he's
never fly he'd never be floating in air
just kind of like just chillin right
they got that in the later ones but if
you if it's a Superman and the laws of
physics combined yeah you'd you'd he'd
be a great leaper he's just a hell of a
long jump hell of a long jumper exactly
all right there do you have a man that
makes sense ok this
is Startalk